صحه شريبتك من تونس
تقاليد وطقوس خاصه تطبع شهر رمضان الكريم
في تونس يبدا التونسيون استعداداتهم
لاستقبال رمضان بتنظيف البيوت واقتناء
اوان جديده وشراء مؤونه الشهر ومن العادات
الحميده التي تسبق دخول رمضان ما يسميه
التونسيون بالقرش والذي يختلف حسب المناطق
ففي الساحل تصنع الفطاير بالزبيب وفي
الشمال الغربي تحضر العصيده بالدقيق
والسمن والعسل اما اهل الجنوب فيطبخون
بركوكش تعد وجبه السحور مهمه بالنسبه
للتونسيين ويحضرون خلالها اطباقا متنوعه
من اهمها العصيده والمصفوف والبسيسه وفي
رمضان تتزين المائده التونسيه باشهى
الاطباق وعلى راسها البريك وهو نوع من
الفطائر المحشوه بالدجاج او اللحم او
البيض الى جانب حساء الفريك من لحم او
الدجاج فستلاطه مشويه اي السلطه المشويه
ومن الاطباق الرئيسيه على المائده
الرمضانيه في تونس الطاجين الذي يحضر
بالجبن والبيض وبعض الخضروات وانواع من
اللحوم ويخبز في الفرن ومن اشهر الحلوات
التقليديه التي يقبل عليها التونسيون في
شهر رمضان زلابيه والمخارق الى جانب
المقروض القيرواني بعد تناول الافطار يحيي
التونسيون بعضهم بعباره صح شريبتك وكلمه
يعود معناها على ما يتناوله الصائم عند
افطاره وفي ليله النصف من رمضان وليله
السابع والعشرين يحضر التونسيون وجبه
الكسكس وغالبا ما تكون بلحم العلوش اي
الخروف يتميز شهر رمضان في تونس بكونه شهر
الافراح حيث يتبرك التونسيون بهذا الشهر
وتقام حفلات الخطبه وفي ليله السابع
والعشرين من رمضان يقدم الخاطب هديه
لخطيبته وتسمى هذه العاده
في الموسم كما تحتفل بعض العائلات في ليله
القدر بختان اطفالها وتنظم سهرات دينيه
تحييها فرق انشاديه يسميها التونسيون
بالسلاميه
[موسيقى]
وهي مجموعه من الفرق التي تؤدي وصلات تمجد
الرسول الكريم صلى الله عليه وسلم ومن
ابرز العادات التونسيه ما يسمى حق الملح
وهي هديه يقدمها الزوج لزوجته في عيد
الفطر تقديرا منه على جهودها خلال شهر
رمضان يحتل شهر رمضان مكانه كبيره في قلوب
التونسيين حيث تمتلئ الجوامع بالمصلين من
اجل الصلاه او سماع الدروس الدينيه التي
تحرس المساجد على زيادتها خلال هذا الشهر
الكريم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]